loading onto this fishing boat is food
medical supplies nappies cooking oil
blankets heaters
and worry and apprehension
mehmed Aaron is heading back to samandar
his hometown flattened in the earthquake
waiting for him he'll find his mother
and three sisters alive at least but now
homeless I got really worried when the
Quake happened but my sister told me
that they were okay then I texted my
friends to make sure they're okay but
most of them didn't respond that's why I
decided to come to my town to help the
rescue operations and I'm bringing food
and medicine to my family Mammoth hopes
he can still find a few people alive but
he knows time is running out
it's a five-hour Crossing but that's
still the fastest way to get to one of
the area's worst hit by the Quake our
trawlers can carry 25 truckloads of Aid
per day so we are able to get much more
aid from across turkey and now
our first stop is the Coast Guard where
most of the official Aid is dropped off
in the morning survivors will be allowed
in to take what they need
then on the other side of the harbor a
is delivered to families who've made
specific requests from relatives
there is nowhere to sleep no one has got
enough Aid yet some Aid is coming but it
is not distributed in an organized way
today I got a sack of flour in several
boxes of aid but I don't know what's in
them
from the third day onwards trucks loaded
with Aid poured into our town only on
the fourth day did heavy duty machines
arrive here
Mehmet is bringing supplies for the tent
his family now calls home he's reunited
with one of his sisters I feel happy and
sad
I see my sister in this situation
it is very bad for me
it's okay
the drive into samandar from the port
reveals the desperate circumstances the
survivors are in still living out of
their cars five days on from the initial
Quake the government has not yet got
tensed through to this town
and this is where that Aid is coming to
and where it is desperately needed more
than 70 percent of the buildings in this
town have been totally destroyed there
is no electricity and there is no sign
of life
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera samandar
Southeastern turkey